if you follow me and you know me
I just know you're gonna roll your eyes at me
when I tell you that we're starting a
five day room renovation
I know and it's okay even I'm rolling my eyes at me at this point
and can I just say spoiler alert
but expect to see a lot of the unhinged thumbs up during this
so obviously it's a bedroom
but whose bedroom is it I hear you wondering
and why we got such a tight headline and
why is that cupboard so fkn messy
all valid questions I'm wondering the same
quick backstory once upon a time when I was 20
my husband and I had a baby
and that baby is about to turn 12
and his bedroom is easily the ugliest
bedroom we have in our entire project house
and this kid deserves the world
so for his birthday he's getting a new room
side note but never have I ever seen wallpaper come off this fkn easily
it was an absolute blessing and we stripped the whole room in 15 minutes
and cause we're doing this room on a budget
well let's be honest we're doing the entire house on a budget
but I'm gonna try and upcycle as many items from the old room as I can
starting out with this lamp from Kmart which I've had for about five years
I painted the lampshade Kohukohunui
and then I went in with te Horo on the base
and both of these colours are from Dulux
then this little side table holds a special place in my heart
because about 20 years ago
it was my side table and
aside from being a little bit old
there's nothing actually wrong with it
which is something I try and tell myself on the daily
I don't know about you
but generally I feel better about myself when I have a bit of foundation on
and I feel like the same theory applies with the side tables
so I'm gonna paint her Crow Valley also by Dulux
and before the wood police come for me
can I just say it's laminate
so no trees were actually harmed in the making of this
and while I worked on my silly little side quest
my husband did actual proper jobs like
putting panelling on the wall
anyway that's everything I had to show for day 1
but it does get significantly more impressive
so come back for the update